baby oh my god I'm gonna give you the
old one for I'm gonna give you your what
- I'm gonna come and get you as soon as
I'm done dancing oh come on let's dance
[ __ ] oh yeah
dig these moves don't know what you guys
are doing I'm getting down and funky
with it
Oh better use my Jedi Mind powers a
brewski what's the matter baby you
afraid of my mind powers I'll fight to
the death
hey come at me bro come at me no get
away from me oh yeah no no Oh get hip
jump jump jump but I go go pick Oh No
I'm a little bit of it yeah
I say we dance we should dance Oh
what you can't beat our team go team go
good job buddy
you got him taking care of them this
breakdancing over here oh hey hey wanna
hear a secret it's really cool hey buddy
you wanna hear another secret
oh my god open the door get on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur what you doing
there what's wrong with your leg bro
what's going on oh my god what the hell
hey come back here no no no don't go
don't go
like a pretty butterfly what did I do
hey dig these moves come on
oh my god what happened Oh what I went
wrong James you and me are gonna go into
the canyon